this committee was established under the
former prime minister it commanded the
confidence of the house at the time and
I'm sure that they've done their work
thoroughly and I respect them for that
obviously this is a matter for the house
uh not for the government and that's why
each and individual colleagues will make
up their own mind when the time comes so
are you not going to be there I said
each and individual colleague will make
up their own mind when the time comes
this is a matter for the house rather
than for the government it's an
important distinction and that's why I
wouldn't want to influence anyone in
advance of that vote but you promised
professionals them accountability
integrity at every level Boris Johnson
has undermined all of those do you not
need to set an example and vote for him
to be punished for that as I said this
is a matter for the house it's not a
government matter this committee was set
up under the former prime minister
they've done their work they've done it
thoroughly and I respect them for that
and now it will just be up to each and
every individual MP to make a decision
on what they want to do when the time
comes it's important that the government
doesn't get involved in that because
it's a matter for Parliament and members
as individuals not as members we're an
individual though thank you I can't let
you go prime minister without asking you
about something that our viewers are
very concerned about and that is
mortgages worrying about paying their
mortgages are you going to help them the
way you help them with energy bills yeah
I know the anxiety that people will have
about mortgage rate that's why the first
priority I set out at the beginning of
the year was to halve inflation because
that's the best and most important way
that we can keep costs and interest
rates down for people we've got a clear
plan to do that it is delivering we need
to stick to the plan but there are
people now there there is also support
available for people we have the
mortgage guarantee scheme for first time
buyers and we have the support for
mortgage interest scheme which is there
to help people as well but look that's
why my first priority is to have
inflation one of my other priorities is
to cut the waiting list and that's why
I've been spending time tonight with the
incredible team at Watford General on
their night shift they're doing great
work and they're also getting the
support from the government thanks very
much indeed